SCP-682 VS SCP-3660.
When the SCP Foundation tested SCP-3660 - The
Zoo Zipper, a zipper that hollows creatures
out and turns their insides into an animal
- against SCP-682, the Hard to Destroy Reptile,
they were hoping to minimize the monster.
The zipper was placed against the creature
while it slept and left in place.
Within seven minutes, it did its thing, unzipping
682 and turning its body into dead rubber:
Only a tiny gecko with 682’s mind came out
of the mess, confused and angry.
Researcher Jettler entered the containment
chamber and stomped on the 682 gecko.
Sadly, this didn’t work out.
The 682 gecko suddenly became 682’s regular
size, while still retaining its gecko appearance,
and ate Researcher Jettler, before breaching
containment and killing several more people.
682 returned to its normal appearance over
the next two weeks.
Test: Failed.